for my final address to this chamber I
don't want to just talk about next year
I want to focus on our future the United
States of America right now has the
strongest most durable economy in the
world anyone claiming that America's
economy is in decline is peddling
fiction working families won't get more
opportunity or bigger paychecks just by
letting big banks or big oil or hedge
funds make their own rules that
everybody else's expense we've cut our
imports of foreign oil by nearly sixty
percent and cut carbon pollution more
than any other country on earth
gasps under two bucks a gallon ain't bad
either let me tell you something the
United States of America is the most
powerful nation on earth period period
in today's world we're threat unless by
evil empires and more by failing States
if this Congress is serious about
winning this war and wants to send a
message to our troops and the world
authorize the use of military force
against ISIL take a vote
with or without congressional action
ISIL will learn the same lessons as
terrorists before them if you doubt
America's commitment or mine to see the
justice is done just ask Osama bin Laden
I will keep working to shut down the
prison at Guantanamo it is expensive it
is unnecessary and it only serves as a
recruitment brochure for our enemies we
need to reject any politics any politics
that targets people because of race or
religion this is not a matter of
political correctness when politicians
insult Muslims whether abroad or our
fellow citizens it's just wrong the
future we want it will only happen if we
fix our politics a better politics
doesn't mean we have to agree on
everything I believe we've got to reduce
the influence of money in our politics
so that a handful
I believe in change because I believe in
you the American people and that's why I
stand here as confident as I have ever
been that the state of our union is
strong thank you
god bless the United States of America